hello and welcome to a special segment
of GameSpot's play for all we are
talking about blank o's block party a
game that has recently been announced
that reminds me a bit of a little big
planet but here to talk to me about it
is chief creative officer of mythical
games jamie jackson how you doing man
hey Michael how's it going man thanks
for having me yeah we're hanging in
there thanks for joining us the first
thing I want to ask is to kind of give a
general overview of what this is for
those who may not be familiar with mykos
block party yeah sure so kwenkos block
party is its kind of an MMO style game
we're coming out in the PC in it's the
essence of it is we bring in vinyl toys
to life so kind of like what I go to my
shoulder I'm you imagine yeah
like when I leave the room where they go
right we kind of created this amazing
world for them to exist but it's kind of
more than just a game as well so we have
a lot of single-player play where you
can go in give you quests you can do
bunch of cool stuff that levels of your
blank O's but you can also build your
own levels as well and share them with
your friends or show more friends you
don't have yet and then there's this
really cool kind of collection mechanic
where you know we're kind of really
focused on players owning what they
purchase I've seen some gameplay and
it's almost like there's platforming
elements it can be a third-person
shooter you can do all sorts of
different like styles of games within it
so what kind of tools are the users
going to be working with yeah so we kind
of you know we wanted to make a game
that gave uses really easy access to
build their own levels right so the kind
of key piece was everything can be built
on a simple controller and the tools are
all about giving you as a player
something you can drop into a level that
you've created and it also generates a
ton of gameplay without you having to be
a level designer or welcome to be able
to understand code or any of that kind
of stuff so you know we refer to them as
toys and in the the first version of
game with season 1 of the game you're
gonna have a shooting mechanic so you
can drop these fun little guns in and
you know the guns are super fun like one
of them's a unicorn kind of sniper rifle
and when you fire it kind of makes
like spring bread you know another one
for his cactus grenades and stuff like
that so you know almost he was like
never on steroids mm-hmm but you can
also do stuff like you know platforming
is a big part of the game the control
system is really inspired by platforming
you know that's something that we're all
big fans of here and what we probably
games we love and having that really fun
control system was always super pointers
so you can do races you can do we
provide collections of vibes so the
little energy that blank boys used to
doing all their power-ups and stuff and
you could think the cool thing is you
can combine them all
so I've literally just come up with play
test we have baby plaintiffs right now
and one of the fun ones we were playing
was a race but halfway through you will
get you will get guns so you get to
grief each other for the last half of
the races tons of fun
can you speak more to the specific
parameters that players will be able to
mess with like how deep does it go can
you control like player accounts party
sizes specific mechanics game rules like
what kind of logic based tools will
people be able to work with yeah what we
try to do is give players enough without
them getting too deep right so you can
set things like weather or you can set
time of day you can set how many what's
the minimum number of the players what's
the maximum number of players you can
set team play you can have like 2v2 3v3
44 you can kind of you can set whether
they start with a gun or whether you
need to go pick a gun up you can set
whether it's team deathmatch or best man
standing and less playing you can set
times everything is kind of we try to
design it you should just feel to you
even use your controller to just tap
through it right so again you know
simple sliders on/off switch is that
kind of stuff
sweet now it sounds like there's gonna
be so much user-generated content that's
kind of what it seems like this game is
gonna be built be built around but in
practice how our player is going to be
able to find that stuff because I
imagine not everyone's gonna want to be
a creator but and would probably want to
focus on being a player so how is that
dynamic gonna work
there's two there's two kind of ways you
can find I guess what we call our play
pillar right so one is you can head to a
place called the junction and the
junction is you know in the in the lore
of Glencoe sits this crazy world that's
up in the sky somewhere that the bankers
have been building over the years right
no one knows quite how how long ago this
place started to get created and there's
a ton of single-player and kind of
team-based content in there for you to
do so gigs and bears we call them and
those things are going to recycle like a
change but so you're gonna have Bailey
tweet these one things you know we
talked about seasons as delivering
content so imagine everything changing
on a seasonal basis as well the junction
changing on a seasonal basis so you can
have a ton of fun in there especially if
you're not into building and you just
want to play you're really into
platforming and you know you're really
into kind of leveling your Blanco up
which is another concept you can do
train instabilities a lot of those gigs
and bears that's where you kind of win
call attachment so you can dress your
Blanco up and different things and then
there's another place you can find it
through your Junction where you can just
pull it up through a menu as well we
call it the party bus and that's where
as a player you can go and start to
search for the content you want to play
and you know think of it kind of like
your Netflix right um you know once you
drop into there it's gonna show you
levels that we know that you'd like to
play right so if you're really into the
team shooters you know we're gonna
slivers up to you um another key thing
for us you know as a team we've been
making games really a really long time
and I think one of the most important
things for players is to be able to get
into a game with just few button prices
as possible so you know we've got quick
play mode in there you can choose the
type of play you want to have so you can
either have what we call party mode
which pits you against other players so
that's when you really want to get into
the MMO side of things but now if you're
just into speedrunning or you want to
play something where you know maybe
you're not in a shoot or you're not in a
live race you can jump into challenge
mode and that's going to stick you into
things that are maybe point-to-point
races and you can start to do speed runs
and that kind of stuff so it's we've
designed it to be really easy to find
the content and then we burn it you know
really easy for you to filter that
content as well yeah speaking of
filtering the content how are you
approaching content moderation because
with UGC being such a heavy focus I
imagine that's that's a difficult thing
to navigate but how are you taking care
of that yeah you're right I mean it is
difficult and a lot of what blanka's is
about is it's really about the community
ownership and the community deciding
what's good right um so we're building
tools for players to get positive
feedback you know what I like to think
of these if you haven't got anything
nice to say don't say anything I think
that's my grandma just tell me anyway
and so that's that's kind of the basis
of what we want to build the levels of
right I think being able to give a
thumbs-up having deeper roots to be able
to give some feedback I think that's
really important but also flagging
content that's offensive is really
important too so you know players are
gonna be able to fly content if you know
if we look at it and it's seemed to be
offensive or whatever like it's a one
strike in your dumb policy with us okay
Wow well now the package content outside
of the UGC you mentioned that there's
gonna be some single-player stuff and
kind of talked a little bit about that
but also sounds like you're going for a
Funko pops meets Toy Story kind of theme
around it can you speak a little bit
more to what may be single-player gamers
are gonna be able to do or what what the
package content will look like at launch
yeah sure it's I mean it's it's kind of
interesting right when you're building
it at them and I memo in the style that
we're building it we're UGC is such a
key part of our game right kind of you
know we want to launch and make sure
that that the party bus has levels for
you to play right from the beginning and
we've got some amazing builders inside
mythical and and some really fun stuff
and even you know even through
development and watching people build
things in a way you didn't expect them
to is is kind of super fun and we've
seen that internally already so once you
want you know first season of the game
you're gonna be able to go to the party
bus and you know minute one there's
gonna be content there for you to have
you two gotten plug and play meet your
friends but there is a pretty
significant single-player gigs and
challenges mode which also for the exist
inside the junction and those could be
anything from like speedruns inside
community events that happen inside
there as well they might get triggered
and everybody assuming that Junction has
to work together to do something fun I
can't talk too much about what that is
yet so there's going to be a ton of
content in there our whole point was the
junction needs to be a place for players
to come back who might not want to jump
into the UGC all the time but they do
want to keep coming back and playing
bancos they do want to train their
Blanco up they want new content so as
they passes you can have new challenges
as a weak passage you're going to have
any challenges and once those things are
gone they've gone as well so you know
some of the rewards that you're gonna
get they're doing those things will be
gone once you've not done it which kind
of neat because it means there's going
to be a ton of stuff in there that some
people have and some people don't have
but I think you know the thing I'm
excited about the most is probably like
day three when the players have built
all their levels and you know they're
gonna show they're gonna build stuff we
didn't even think about yeah and I
imagine there's gonna be a lot of
players who hop on because if I recall
correctly this is gonna be a
free-to-play game yeah that's right um
you know we think free to play it's kind
of the way think this kind of a future
right I think having players coming
there's gonna be a lot of content for
people to play for free but we also see
this as a seasonal thing now which you
know twelve year old me would be so
happy will happen to wait two years for
sequel or whatever right so you know to
deliver really meaningful content for
people on a seasonal basis we're really
excited about it we have a lot in the
pipeline can you speak to how
monetization is gonna work yeah for sure
so you know we definitely see Blanco as
a seasonal thing so for us it's about
delivering really valuable content to
players seasonally you're gonna be able
to buy bancos you're also gonna be able
to buy construct kits and constructor
kids to kind of the UGC side I was
thinking bit a bit like Lego right you
know used to get the Lego and you look
at the friend you can build all that
you've got all these other options on
the back of it as well so you buy those
things you can drop them into your level
you can modify them but you also don't
need to buy those to build stuff as well
you know there's a ton of content and
UGC that's just for each
sweet yeah you mentioned that you'll be
able to buy a blank O's and do a lot of
customization can you give a little bit
more details on the different ways in
which we can customize our characters
and the world around us yes so from a
blanket point of view you're going to be
able to add lots of different cosmetics
and just to kind of make them look a bit
cool or whatever it might be whether
it's sneakers or chains or backpacks and
hats and masks and stuff like that some
of them are going to have abilities as
well so we've got jetpacks you've
probably seen the bat wings in the
trailer which are pretty cool so
definitely some of the things are gonna
help your blank oh and another thing
kind of going back to UGC you can tag
whether a player can use these or not in
a level so if you think oh you know
everyone's got speed shoes it's gonna
ruin it for everyone on this level
you'll actually tag it's a speed shoes
aren't allowed on this run and it
automatically removes it for a player so
we kind of really tried to think about
how players can very easily make sure
that any of our ability attachments
don't ruin anything that they've built
alright man last question I got for you
is now that this is going to be a live
service game and there's just gonna be
evolving over time with the stuff that
people create and the different things
that you're going to implement in the
game I'm just gonna be changing a lot
and it's gonna have a long tail so I got
to ask
can you speak to anything on your end
about how you're going to adopt moving
to a new generation because I imagine
really saying game in 2020 is a very
different thing with the next console
generation on the on the cusp yeah I
mean I've I think with every console
generation in my career well everything
for PlayStation 1 anyway and there's
always an interesting time for us focus
on PC right now is really important
because PC is this amazing place that
kind of skips all console things in some
way right here and it just continues to
exist simple open I'm super excited
about that because it gives us that
focus so we're just super focused on
making a really good PC build right now
but we do have some great console plans
and I'm going to be really excited but
just not yet now before I let you go is
there anything else you want to say
before
you go if you guys want to sign up for
an account or you want to check out
what's going on head over to blank words
calm the betta is gonna be like before
the end of the year so get your name on
the list if you're interested in being
in that and if you want to follow us
we're on Instagram and Twitter or play
bankers of course that is Jamie Jackson
from mythical games and Blancos Bloc
Party is on its way and I want to thank
you all for watching and taking the time
to sit with us here we have so much more
content here on gamespot comm so be sure
to check out all the stuff that we've
been working on with play for all and
check out our daily live streams as well
thank you again and we'll see you next
time
[Music]